le réveillon parlons-en pour ceux
d'entre vous qui s'apprête à en faire
une fête tout parure d'or france roche a
quelques idées tout en paillettes
quelques idées pour vous habiller pour
le vert que je porte je me suis dit
qu'il ressemblait un arbre de noël parce
qu'il était vert plein de petites boules
multicolores et j'étais site et de le
porter pour le réveillon et puis l'idée
a fait son chemin smokin rouge père noël
des semailles tôt et jambières diamanté
de minitel vous allez voir que nous
n'avons pas triché sur les jeans les
voici tous couvre long large serré
indigo de la v9 fusée clouté accompagné
d'une blouse ornés de boules de noël par
olivier elle d'un châle de métal par
paco rabanne
et très réveillon s'adosse à l'est mad
max kohl en cuir et jersey d' colette
nivelles la brassière étoilé d'or de
lanvin
poulot vers diamanté de l'habitus jean
patou imagine sur un lévis prêt
classique un spencer avec ville est très
1900 pour accompagner une chemise là
mais de cardin
le papillon de cheveux de boules et de
pommes de pin a été fait par georges
saint gilles il n'est pas à la portée de
tous les peignes ni le smoking de
paillettes de place plus à la portée de
toutes les aiguilles ou alors il aurait
fallu commencer à coudre en octobre le
monsieur en verre et chemise noire de
docteurs et de cheyrou ti enfin la
blouse virginale de balma et bien mariés
disons fiancée avec le gilet clouté de
strass et le jean bordés de faux
diamants de l'habitus nous ferrons
conseil le lamellé plumes avec le denim
le plus usé et site avec des articles de
bazar que saint gilles vous faire
ressembler à une impératrice
e